Black Panther is already being hailed as an
astonishing installment to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, with tight direction, top-of-the-line
performances, and stunning action sequences.
The studio's had no trouble commanding an
audience over the last decade, of course,
but with Black Panther, it looks like they're
delivering a truly special cinematic experience,
and here's why.
Behind the lens talent
Black Panther might only be director Ryan
Coogler's third feature film, but there are
plenty of reasons Marvel trusted him to kick
off its all-new franchise.
For starters, even though his filmography
is limited, it's still quite impressive.
His first feature, Fruitvale Station, won
the Grand Jury Prize at Sundance and garnered
near-universal acclaim.
And his second movie, Creed, instantly became
known as one of the best entries in the Rocky
series, and cleaned up at the box office,
too.
Perhaps most importantly, he also just so
happens to be a lifelong Black Panther superfan,
which was a big factor in the hiring process.
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige told
Entertainment Weekly:
"[Coogler made the film] for his 8-year old
self."
"Most importantly, you do it for other 8-year-olds,
to inspire the next generation the way we
were inspired.
And in this case, when Ryan was growing up,
perhaps there weren't that many of these heroes
to be inspired by that looked like him."
It appears that having someone with a real
heart for the art at the helm obviously paid
off here.
A true leading man
T'Challa was introduced to film audiences
in 2016's Captain America: Civil War, a movie
already stuffed to the brim with heroes.
Even though the movie had a frenetic pace
and tons of heroes to deal with, Chadwick
Boseman's regal performance really sold audiences
on the Wakandan superhero.
And in Black Panther, he steadily commands
the screen as the rousing royal.
"I am ready."
Perhaps it's no surprise that Boseman is impressing
audiences in the film.
After all, he'd already been a cinematic force
with leading roles in movies like 42 and Get
On Up.
Compelling villainy
No Ryan Coogler film would be complete without
the director's muse, Michael B. Jordan.
The actor starred in both of Coogler's prior
pictures, and this time, he's getting to do
something totally new.
Jordan stars in Black Panther as Eric Killmonger,
an exiled Wakandan-turned-U.S. Black Ops soldier
who returns to challenge T'Challa for the
throne.
As with his last two Coogler collaborations,
Jordan's work in the film is already being
hailed as "the best MCU villain since Loki".
"I'mma burn it all."
Considering how much trouble Marvel movies
have had making satisfying screen baddies
lately, that's high praise for the red-hot
actor's work in the movie.
Scene stealers
With all of the A-listers starring in Black
Panther it might be hard to believe that an
up-and-comer has emerged as the scene-stealer
of the whole film.
But that's exactly what happened with Letitia
Wright as Shuri.
"WOO!
Let's go!"
You might recognize Wright as Renie in Humans
or as Nish in Black Mirror's "Black Museum"
episode.
But after Black Panther, she's bound to be
as big of a star as anyone else on the film's
roster.
The character is brilliant, spritely, and
a complete standout that'll definitely make
audiences smile.
And Shuri isn't the only one with some major
girl power in Black Panther.
The characters Okoye and Nakia, played by
Danai Gurira and Lupita Nyong'o respectively,
have also received high marks for badassery.
Mood music
If the filmmaking and acting talent involved
in the film wasn't impressive enough, the
film's soundtrack is also brimming with exciting
voices.
Kendrick Lamar produced the album and managed
to round up hip-hop favorites like Schoolboy
Q, Vince Staples, Future, The Weeknd, and
SZA to contribute tracks alongside Lamar himself.
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy soundtracks
might've made waves for reviving some old
favorites, but Black Panther is taking things
a step further with an original album that's
already got people talking.
Action satisfaction
It just wouldn't be a Marvel movie without
a ton of action-packed set pieces, and Black
Panther delivers on that angle just as well
as everywhere else.
The film's fight scenes have drawn comparisons
to slick action fare like the Kingsmen and
James Bond series for their sophistication
levels, and there's at least one massive chase
scene that should get audiences' adrenaline
properly pumping as well.
Post-credit impact
Another signature Marvel move is to include
post-credit sequences, and the two featured
in Black Panther seem to be signals for what's
ahead.
Without spoiling them, let's just say that
they point to a brave new future for the Kingdom
of Wakanda and connect the dots between prior
Marvel films and what's to come with Avengers:
Infinity War.
Cultural pride
It's no secret that Western films have a history
of portraying African nations as being impoverished
and violent.
However, with a mainstream film like this
one showcasing more of the vibrant and beautiful
aspects of African culture, the film has the
potential to change the way Hollywood treats
the birthplace of humanity.
As Lupita Nyong'o, who was raised in Kenya,
put it:
"...Marvel has a way of really affecting popular
culture, and to have that popular culture
informed with things that are of African origin
… is powerful.
Hopefully it changes the general idea of what
being an African is.
Too often times we see Africa as a place that
is wanting, and here it's a place that you
want to go."
So, beyond just being entertainment, Black
Panther could very well represent a moment
of cultural awakening altogether.
The way that the film's talent celebrated
native fashion at the premiere, it seems to
have already arrived as a source of pride.
Not only that, but the movie could also re-shape
the way studios think about black cinema as
a whole.
Lately, black directors have been having more
and more success getting their stories onto
screens.
Coogler's contemporaries such as Ava DuVernay
and Jordan Peele have been steadily proving
that cinematic stories told from a black cultural
viewpoint can not only give young black audiences
the kind of representation they've been yearning
for but also generate boatloads of cash.
Perhaps it'll take a pop culture titan like
Marvel to drive this point home once and for
all, but if it does, Black Panther could be
a serious game changer.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!